if you were underwhelmed by this year's
robert downey jr vehicle
do little you weren't alone and one of
the flicks script doctors knows why
seth rogen who was brought in to do an
uncredited punch-up on doolittle
screenplay had some harsh words about
the film during a recent conversation
with howard stern
according to him the whole production
was essentially a house of cards waiting
to come crashing down
rogan often serves as a writer on his
own films but it's not exactly common
knowledge that he's often tapped to
rehab problematic screenplays
so respected are his writing skills in
the case of doolittle
he says that he immediately recognized
the project for what it was
an empty shell rogan told stern some
movies are like scams
it's like buying blueprints to a house
that looks nice
but when you try to actually build the
house it doesn't stand up properly
that is a thing that that happens with
films and and i recognize it sometimes
where i will see a movie and be like oh
they lied whoever wrote and directed
this movie lied that's pretty brutal but
rogan wasn't done
he went on to suggest that the creative
minds behind doolittle
knew that the project was a half-baked
one when they sold the brass at
universal on the picture
he dished they made it seem like they
were selling the studio an actual
functional film but they did not they
sold them like the schematics of a movie
that
when built does not hold up to stress
testing he added
i'll only say this because it was
reported and i'm going to tread lightly
because
i am close with many of the people
involved but i did that on the dr
doolittle film
rogan went on to explain that while the
job of a script doctor is a relatively
low pressure one from a professional and
creative standpoint
that shouldn't be taking the mean that
those brought in to fix what maybe can't
be fixed have no horse in the race at
all
he explained that it's a pretty cushy
position to be in
adding stakes are low for you personally
but it's also like you want to help i
like movies and i like the actors in
that movie and i don't want anyone to
not be happy with the movie
on the other hand though the writer
implied that on some projects
trying to wrangle the script into
submission is akin to slapping a
band-aid on the whole of the titanic
do doolittle was such a project and
universal pretty much knew it
rogan continued saying universal has
been very supportive of me and my career
and made a lot of our movies and i like
the people who work there
so i genuinely want to make things
better if i can
but the studio was having problems with
the movie and we're calling in people to
help kind of get to the bottom of it
[Music]
robert downey jr is one of the most
charismatic actors of his generation
perhaps only he could have taken what
was in 2008
a c-list marvel superhero and built not
only a trilogy around him
but a mega franchise destined to go down
in history as the most ambitious
cinematic undertakings ever
even he however couldn't save doolittle
the first project he took on after
wrapping up his 11-year run as iron man
in the marvel cinematic universe
from collapsing all the way down to its
ramshackle foundations
released in january 2020 well before the
covet 19 pandemic shuttered theaters
nationwide
doolittle drew a dismal 14 rating on
review aggregator rotten tomatoes
with critics slam-basting every aspect
of the production
from the photography to the editing to
yes the writing which was found to be
full of lame potty humor in service of a
meandering
borderline formless plot something
smelled wrong
and that's coming from a guy who loves
the smell of butts even rdj
a consummate professional seemed to be
phoning it in perhaps aware that the
only good thing to come out of the film
was gonna be his paycheck
do little bombed at the box office and
deservedly so
it was one of the first true turkeys of
2020 and it appears that we now know why
it just wasn't built to be anything but
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one